y no deja de sorprender realmente como
algunos votantes no se toman en serio y
eso habla también de cierta manera una
desconexión de la realidad del país
porque si bien estas elecciones podrían
perjudicar a un sector de la población
hay muchas personas que votaron por eso
porque saben que de pronto su estatus no
cambie mucho pero aquí hay mucho en
juego realmente aquí hay que ver que si
llegaba el caso que trump gandhi muchas
personas que tienen obama que estén
comprometidos que son más de 20 millones
de personas con ese servicio médico que
no será el más perfecto pero es el que
los ha mantenido de cierta manera en
esta pandemia que siguen creciendo
también está el tema de daca que es el
tema de los
ustedes saben estos reimers que son
estos muchachos que llegaron muy jóvenes
a eeuu que son de padres 5
indocumentados pero que vinieron aquí a
eeuu a una muy temprana y prácticamente
son considerados estadounidenses por
cultura esa provisión podría ser
derogada teniendo en cuenta como le
decía al invitado en bogotá que hay una
corte suprema en su gran mayoría con ser
está también el tema bueno de los de los
derechos reproductivos de la mujer
porque bien sabemos que en y conny
perrin pues no es muy simpatizante de
los derechos que tiene la mujer respecto
al aborto y el derecho a ese servicio oa
esa tec a esa a ese tema también está el
tema del cambio climático de hecho es
algo que poco se ha hablado en esta
contienda y es que eeuu oficialmente hoy
se ha retirado del acuerdo de parís así
que no sabemos cómo va a ser el futuro
realmente de esta iniciativa a nivel
mundial cuando eeuu es uno de los
principales sino el principal
contaminador y emisor de gases de
invernadero en este mundo